Let us now illustrate the linear
least mean squares estimation
methodology in the
context of an example.
And we're going to revisit
our familiar example
that we considered earlier in
the context of general least
mean squares estimation.
Let us remind
ourselves what were
the assumptions
behind this example.
There is an unknown
random variable
that we wish to estimate, and
that random variable happens
to be uniform on the
range from 4 to 10.
What we get to observe
is a random variable X,
which is equal to Theta
plus or minus something.
So X is Theta plus a noise term.
And that noise term
can be anything
in the range from
minus 1 to plus 1.
Furthermore, the
distribution of U
is this particular
uniform no matter
what theta is, so Theta
and U are independent.
These modeling assumptions
correspond to this picture.
This is the range
of X and Theta.
And the joint distribution
of X and Theta
happens to be a
uniform distribution
on this particular shape.
However, we're not really going
to use this picture other than
for illustration purposes.
You could take just this as
the formulation of the problem
that we're interested in.
So now, to develop the form of
the optimal linear estimator,
all we need to do
is to determine
the various constants
that show up.
So let's start
with expectations.
Theta is uniform from 4 to 10.
Therefore, the expected
value is the midpoint,
which is equal to 7.
U has a symmetric
distribution around 0,
so its expected value is
going to be equal to 0.
X is the sum of Theta
and U. Therefore,
its expected value is the sum
of these two expected values
and is equal to 7.
Let us now look at variances.
The variance of a uniform
is equal to the square
of the length of the interval
on which the uniform is
distributed-- in this case,
it's 6 squared-- divided always
by a coefficient of 12.
6 squared is 36,
so we obtain three.
The variance of U is determined
by a similar formula,
except that now we have
an interval of length 2,
so we obtain 2 squared over 12.
And this is 1/3.
Now let us look at
the variance of X.
Since X is the sum of Theta and
U, and since the two of them
are independent,
the variance of X
is going to be the sum of
these two variances, which
is 10 over 3.
Now let us try to calculate
the covariance term.
The covariance of Theta
with X is this expression,
because X is Theta
plus U. And then,
using linearity
properties of covariances,
this is the covariance
of Theta with itself,
plus the covariance
of Theta with U. Now,
Theta and U are independent, so
this covariance is equal to 0.
The covariance of
Theta with itself
is just the same
as the variance,
so here we obtain
an answer of 3.
And so now we have all
the pieces of information
that we need, and we can
proceed and write down
the form of the
linear estimator.
The expected value
of Theta is 7.
Then, the covariance
of Theta with X
is 3, divided by the
variance, which is 10 over 3.
So this ratio becomes 9/10.
And then X minus the expected
value of X gives us this term.
So this is the form of the
optimal linear estimator,
and if you wish to plot it,
it is a curve of this kind.
It is actually interesting
to contrast this solution
to the shape of the optimal
estimator, the least mean
squares estimator, or the
conditional expectation
estimator, which we
had found earlier,
and which corresponds to
this particular blue curve.
So in some sense,
the linear estimator
is a pretty good approximation
of the optimal non-linear one.
It does the best
job that it can do,
subject to the constraint that
it has to be a linear function.
Notice also that this
coefficient here is, of course,
positive.
This reflects the fact that
the two random variables,
X and Theta, are
positively correlated.
This should be clear
from this diagram.
When X increases, Theta tends to
also increase, and vice versa.
It's also reflected in the
fact that the covariance
is a positive number.
On the other hand,
because this coefficient
is 9/10 and not equal
to 1, this red line
is somewhat slanted
in comparison
with the orientation of
the diagram that we have.
The calculations
that we went through
in this particular example
are pretty generic.
This is what you need
to do in general.
You just look at the
random variables involved,
you calculate their means,
you calculate their variances.
Then you may have to
do some extra work
to calculate the
covariance of interest.
And once you're done, you
plug in the numerical values
that you have found,
and you obtain
the form of the
linear estimator.